the intruder was directed by Deon Taylor
and stars Michael Ealy Megan good and
Dennis Quaid and is a story of a very
successful couple that buy a new house
from Dennis Quaid his character used to
live there and is very attached to this
house and as they move in they begin to
notice that he keeps coming over a lot
he wants to cut the grass he wants to
help with home projects he's inviting
himself over quite often and he begins
to make the situation very uncomfortable
and as you might expect eventually
violence ensues and horrible things
happen there was something I could not
help but think about while I was
watching this movie and that's a film
called Cold Creek Manor that came out in
2003 that starred Dennis Quaid Sharon
Stone Stephen Dorff and a young Kristen
Stewart that film was about Dennis Quaid
and Sharon Stone who bought an old house
Stephen Dorff shows up and says no this
is my house I live here he wants to help
around the house with projects and
eventually violence ensues and now we
have Dennis Quaid playing the Stephen
Dorff character it's almost like a weird
pseudo spin-off in an alternate universe
this film was distributed by Sony Screen
Gems that makes quite a bit of films
with the same cast members I've talked
about this in the past on my channel I
think when the bough breaks was the last
time I discussed this where they kind of
have this revolving door of the same
cast members that appear in the same
films Morris Chestnut Michael 1 - he's
in a lot of films made by Sony Screen
Gems and they all have a similar feel a
similar budget a similar plot they all
go for the same type of modest thrills
while also having a lot of pg-13 sex and
the intruder is no different this film
is littered with false jump scares that
become unintentionally hilarious after a
while a musical score so obvious that
you can see everything that's about to
happen coming a mile away because the
music warns you tons of unnecessary
gratuitous MTV music video sex scenes
with the camera panning up Megan Goods
body like she's some object and a third
act with a bunch of scenes that are
supposed to be scary but really just
come off as very uncomfortable but the
worst fault of this movie is its script
and how it treats its characters and how
it asks us as the audience to accept the
dumbest decisions I've seen
characters making a movie in months
these guys are so so stupid and I just
can't get behind them it actually makes
the characters that you're supposed to
be rooting for extremely unlikable to
the point where you're actually rooting
for the villain the progression of the
plot which is by the way stretched out
somehow to over 100 minutes even though
this should be like an 85 minute movie
relies entirely on Meghan Goods
character feeling sorry for Dennis
Quaid's character she feels bad he's
created this backstory that makes him
look good and Michael Ealy is jealous
because Meghan good likes Dennis Quaid a
little bit but that's okay cuz Michael
Ealy's off at his job flirting with
random people and flirting with
customers and flirting with people that
he might sleep with and there's all of
this relationship baggage that set up
throughout this movie that leads to
nothing and I mean nothing
it's just there to elongate the runtime
there's probably 20 minutes of scenes
here that could be removed the best part
of the movie in fact I'm gonna go out on
a limb here and say the only good part
of this film is Dennis Quaid he is
giving a suitably over-the-top
performance and this movie does not
deserve this performance he is the only
person in the film that seems to be
having fun who understands how to make a
film like this as good as it could be
everyone else in the movie is taking it
so so seriously no doubt from direction
that was given to them to be that
serious that it makes it hard to
appreciate the type of b-movie thriller
this could have been with Dennis Quaid's
fun performance and a considerably more
tongue-in-cheek and in the no screenplay
this could have been really cool but
it's just trying to be so goddamn
serious it thinks it's this amazing
story and it's just not it's the same
story we've seen a thousand times
speaking of that I want to talk about a
film that came out last year called
traffic this film starred Paula Patton
it was also directed by Deon Taylor and
I saw it in theaters and I really did
not like it in fact I didn't review his
movie last year because I honestly felt
kind of bad because it was a small film
and I was like alright I wasted my time
I wasted my money but I'm
kind of shit all over his movie it's a
tiny movie people will see it it'll make
its budget back that's fine then I saw
this film this is the second time I've
paid for one of his films and it's the
same movie just shifted around the first
film traffic was about sex trafficking
and it had Paula Patton and Omar Epps as
a couple that were in the woods and some
sex traffickers attacked them and then
they have to run from them and that's
basically the third act but the first
act the movie was just sex scenes with
Paula Patton camera panning all over her
body needlessly like she was some object
and then all of a sudden that tried to
have a message about sex trafficking in
there but it was also trying to be a
thriller produced by Sony Screen Gems
that made money that was like a weird
music video for like the first act and
it was just kind of shameless but I was
like you know what whatever then I saw
this movie and it was the same thing it
was the same thing it was a movie that
tried to sneak in themes we're gonna get
into some spoilers here and I just I
have to I have to because it's actually
something that kind of bothered me like
I was like this is a little shameless
and kind of sad actually so if you
wanted to see the intruder I'm gonna
talk about some things that happen in
the end of the film right now but I'm
obviously not really recommending that
you see it or waste your money on this
movie so that's your spoiler warning
here we go so randomly in the movie
Michael Elise character says that
someone he loved I forget if it was his
brother or his cousin I think it was his
brother was gunned down in the street
and so he hates guns
he doesn't want guns in the house at all
guns are very bad he hates them please
don't bring guns near by the house but
he just he says this you know we don't
we don't even get a flashback at least
like that the most basic form of show
don't tell we are told this happens
that's all we know in this one quick
scene there's a lot of exposition like
that where the characters just sort of
spout what happened to them or or people
show up at a bar and we learn about a
backstory with Dennis Quaid's character
because someone just tells us and we're
like oh so that's what really happened
it happens consistently it's very lazy
screenwriting so at the end of the film
though throughout all of this movie
where we've had Michael Ealy every time
he sees Dennis Quaid holding a gun
because when we first meet Dennis
he's hunting a deer and Michael Ellie's
freaked out by this gun he's like don't
come near me with this gun so we have
this theme throughout it you know where
guns are bad and stuff then at the end
of the movie Michael Ellie's got a gun
and Dennis Quaid has been beaten you
know almost to death and Michael Ealy
shoots Dennis Quaid with the gun and
says go to hell then the end credits
start with the song gripped up by
Casanova I just started laughing it was
like wow this movie tried to have a
message about gun violence then it took
its lead character had him hold a gun
say go to hell like it was commando all
of a sudden he shoots the bad guy and
then we get gripped up by Casanova like
it's some cool action movie or something
like what's your message here what's the
message of this movie it makes no sense
it's a shameless film with horrible
characters with one good performance in
it and it's stretched so long with like
20 minutes of scenes that could be cut
out this is a really bad movie but it
could become an unintentionally funny
movie that you might watch it parties if
you just want to laugh or have a good
time or if you just want to see a movie
where you sort of shout at the screen a
lot this is definitely that film for you
I'm gonna give the intruder a d-minus
Dennis Quaid's over-the-top performance
was the best part of the movie and this
film should have been like that and it
just didn't appreciate what it had and
it tried to be so overly serious guys if
he did see the film let me know what he
thought I wouldn't recommend it obscene
play guys thank you so much for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]